There's a new report estimating proportion
of Donald Trump's carrots were paid by Americans,
and I'm not going to keep you in suspense.
I'll tell you right away, the number is 100%
100% of Donald Trump's tariffs were paid by
Americans.
And if this is shocking to you, do you either
weren't paying attention or don't understand
how tariffs work because we've been sounding
the alarm about this since the day that Donald
Trump started talking about putting these
tariffs on China.
It doesn't matter how many times Donald Trump
says China pays the tariffs.
China does not pay the tariffs.
Here's one example from just a few days ago
repeating it doesn't make it any more true.
Donald Trump tweeting quote the United States
treasury has taken in many billions of dollars
from the tariffs.
We are charging China and other countries
that have not treated us fairly.
In the meantime, we are doing well in various
trade negotiations, capitalizing T and trade
and in negotiations currently going on.
At some point, this had to be done.
The treasury has taken in the money.
That part is true, but the money is not coming
from China.
We are not Chinese charging China anything.
A working paper by economists at the federal
reserve bank of New York as well as a, um,
uh, a Columbia professor, David Weinstein.
And um, Princeton's Stephen Redding determined
that approximately 100% of the Trump administration's
tariffs have been paid by us, by Americans.
Let's explain if Chinese steel costs $20 per
square foot.
Okay.
And Donald Trump puts a 10% tariff on Chinese
steel.
An American company still pays China.
They're $20 per square foot, and then they
give $2 per square foot, that 10% tariff to
the United States treasury.
What did China pay?
Nothing.
China's still got their $20 per square foot.
The American company pays for it, not China,
not China.
How many times do we have to say this?
And then if you're an American, uh, building
a house for example, and you have a house
that's partially made of steel, the fact that
your builder paid a 10% tariff on the steel
and gets passed along to you, to the end user.
If you're buying a car that uses steel, the
car will be bumped up in cost by the manufacturer
to account for the fact that they have paid
the tariff.
We pay for it, not the Chinese.
I imagine Donald Trump has this mental image
of Chinese billionaires sitting around writing
checks to the United States for his tariffs
when it's really just middle-class families
here in the United States that end up paying
more for stuff, their house, their car, whatever
products from China.
Does Donald Trump not understand or is he
understanding it?
But he's choosing to lie and to Gaslight because
he knows the truth is actually really bad.
The headline should not be Americans pay 100%
of tariffs.
The headlines should be, people are so clueless
about tariffs that it is newsworthy that Americans
are paying 100% of the tariffs.
This is less about people being uneducated
than it is about people being deliberately
miseducated because a lot of people did look
into this, they researched, uh, they're not
fake news sources and they were given an incorrect
explanation that agreed with what Donald Trump
is saying publicly.
So maybe research is a bit of a stretch, but
people, you know, they checked what their
cousin posted on Facebook.
It's, they sort of tried and there was a huge
disinflation campaign around the tariffs about
how this is Trump being strong and this is
going to hurt China and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
Fox news is strong.
Trump lackeys are powerful in terms of the
media presence that they are given to show
up and recite their talking points.
And the whole concept of being able to learn
about the world by watching the news has been
completely bastardized as it's been taken
over by partisan and corporate interest.
And that's how you end up with a headline
that actually surprises people.
Like 100% of Trump's tariffs paid by Americans.
We've been sounding the alarm since day one.
That's the way tariffs work.
And the really shocking thing is that so many
people fell for it.
And by the way, Trump did this from day one,
Trump from day one of his campaign, or very
early on when he figured out that this China
trade stuff was beneficial to him, probably
because his followers didn't understand it.
So they would just believe whatever he said
he ran on.
I understand trade, I understand economics,
I understand currency manipulation.
I'm going to do terrorists, we're going to
deal with it all.
I'm the guy, I'll renegotiate trade deals
and all this stuff.
So he very successfully and effectively primed
his followers so that then when he did whatever,
once he was actually president, they would
just think that it was good.
And I would not be surprised.
You know when you talk to Trumpists and you
say, what does Donald Trump done that you
really like?
Very often you get absolute nonsense like
nothing.
They don't, they can't even really say anything.
They just say he's strong, he's honest, he's
moral, he's a good businessman, whatever.
There are some who will actually be able to
put together some kind of policy and they'll
say, I really like what he's done with trade.
I really like what he's done with the tariffs
and of course they will have absolutely no
idea that they are the ones paying for those
tariffs.
It's been very successful and whether or not
the mango menace understands how tariffs work.
It really doesn't matter.
As long as his followers think he did the
right thing and it's helping them, they will
vote to reelect him in November
of 2020